[音楽]
青木里の人生経営哲学100回聞いたら
豊かになる話早速ですが第1回目はえ成功
者と達成者の最大の違いは何かということ
について青木社長の徹学教えていただけれ
ばと思いますなるほど
[音楽]
このも達成者も共通校はま物事を
成し遂げるということにおいては同じだと
思うんだよねでま能力とは何かというと
物事を成し遂げる力と僕は定義してるんだ
けどそういう意味においては成功者も達成
者も物事成し遂げるという意味においては
とても大切な能力だと思いますただその
成功とは
何かあのノアウェブスターというアメリカ
の学問の知と言われるノアウェブスターが
ね成功とは探し求めた目標の満足行く達成
と定義しているのでただ達成したら良いっ
ていうんではないんだよね満足行く達成
これ非常に大事なテーマだと思うんです
あのま僕は実は若い頃あのプロのセールス
の世界でトップセールスになりトップ
マネージャーになり数々の書を取ったんだ
けど実は若い時達成者だったんだけど成功
者ではなかったし幸せでもなかった達成し
ても幸せではないでもま人生色々こう
キャリアを積んできてま成功とは何かと
さっきののはウェブスターの定義にもある
ようにじゃあ僕は何を求めているんだろう
探し求めた目標の満足だから何を求めてる
のかというと結局それはゴールではなくて
パーパス目的だっっていうことに気づいた
ん人生の目的は幸せになることなのでま
その何かを成し遂げても家族が一下離散だ
とか病気になってしまったり何かトタル
バランスという意味においてえ本当に求め
てる人生を手にできてない人もたくさん見
てきましただからやっぱり真の成功という
のは私は成し遂げるというだけではなくて
みんなにとって
望ましいトータルバランスという概念が
そこに求められてるんじゃないかなとま私
なりの捉え方ですけどねそんな風に思って
ますありがとうございますはい逆にその
達成者から成功者になんか変わってく
なんかポイントとかきっかけうんいうのっ
てあったりするんです
[音楽]
かそうですねま結局ねま成功者はキリの
ようにある一点に向かって働くということ
をよく昔からね言われるんですよまキリ
っていうのはこうバーってやって穴が開く
わけですよねでもまそこには集中があるだ
から達成するということは当然のこと
ながら思考と行為をこの願望実現に向けて
集中しているので物事達成するんだけど
その時に周りを踏み台にしたりつまりえ
ウンルーズの状態なのかルーズウンの状態
なのかウンウンの状態なのかやっぱり大事
なことは共に勝つという考え方が僕は求め
られてると思うので若い時は勝ち負けでも
しょうがないんですよ
でもある年齢になった時に共に歩む人の
ことも考えながらやっぱりこう組織的に共
に物事を成し遂げていけるまそんな人生を
僕は大切にしてきましたねま決して今自分
自身成功してるとは思ってないこれは
あくまでも僕は障害チャレンジャーだと
思います成功というのはあの他の人からの
評価あの人が成功してるとか色々見られる
かもしれないけどただ物事を成し遂げ
るっていうことに関しては私はとても
こだわってきたし全て成し遂げてきたのは
事実ですで今結局ま会社であるたりま家族
であったり私を取り囲む人たちが幸せか
どうかというのがやっぱり真の成功という
意味においては大切なポイントかなと思い
ますけどねはいありがとうございます
なんかウンウンという言葉はすごくこう
聞いてると綺麗素敵だなと思うんです
けれども一方でやっぱりどこかそのウン
ルーズからウンウンになんか切り替えてい
くっていうとちょっと違う世界の話という
かなんか綺麗事のように聞こえることって
すごくあると思うんですけどなんかうん
うんうんその青木社長自身が切り替わった
タイミングだったりとか逆にどうしたらそ
こってなんかウンウンの方に視点を変えて
いけるのかっていうのてありますうん
[音楽]
うんこれはねすごく良い質問だと思うんだ
けどもあのスペシャリストって別に世の
ため人のためになんだろう例えば
アスリートにしてもねま今世界で1番活躍
してる日本人は大谷翔平さんだと思うん
ですよま私もあの大谷翔平さんのことを
とても尊敬してますま花巻東高校のね立子
夢実現プロジェクト私たちも10年間
サポートさせてもらってますけれども彼は
でも日本のために野球してるわけじゃない
よね自分の描いている理想の姿やっぱり
世界一の野球人になるというその理想が彼
の中にあってでそれは能力だけじゃなくて
やっぱり人格的にもこういう人間になり
たいという彼の中にある理想が結果的に
周りの人に大きな感動を与えそして彼の
あり方やり方じゃだけじゃなくてあり方が
彼のあの遺体な業績を作り出してると私は
捉えてるんですよでやっぱり大谷翔平さん
の死は佐々木浩さんというま花巻東のえ
公式野球部の監督なんですこの佐々さんの
教育価値観教育ですよねこれが私はあの
大谷翔平さんの偉大な業績を作り出してる
と思いますだからそのま組織者としての
成功ということとスペシャリストとしての
成功これはやはりちょっとまた捉え方が
違うかもしれないでも本質は一緒なんです
けどやっぱり自分のその求めてるものに
対して周りの人たを決してですね踏み台に
しないやっぱり自分の求めてるものを得た
時に周りが素晴らしいとやっぱり賞賛して
くれる状態これが私は望ましいと思います
でうんだからスペシャリストの人たちま
アスリートにしても芸術家にしてもみんな
そうですけども自分の理想を追求して物心
両面の豊かな人生を手に入れいで私は組織
者としてま37年前に社員5名資本金
500万で会社スタートしましたまそして
結果的に今おかげ様で社員も200名に
なりそしてま会社はま100億円以上の
価値になりましたでもそれはお金を追って
きたわけじゃないんですよ大谷さんも絶対
にお金を追ってあのを出してるわけじゃ
ないんですよ自分の理想を追求した結果
周りから見てその価値にふさわしい評価で
何百億という契約金とかが生まれてくる
わけで私もそうなんですよね自分の中で
やっぱりこの仕事を通してこういうことを
成し遂げたいこうやってみんなに喜んで
もらいたいその思いが結果的にま経済的に
も精神的にも豊かになり自分の周りの人
たちも豊かになるという現象が生まれてる
わけですよだから大事なことはやっぱり
やり方も大事だけどあり方そしてその
やっぱり目的じゃないかなそこの目的を
大切に
するやぱパーパスていうことでしょうね
ゴールはあくまでもその目的を
遂げるための通貨点でしかないんですよね
だからやっぱ目的にきるっていうことは
キーワードだと思いますけどねうん
ありがとうございますはい最後にあの青木
社長まポイントは目的に生きることだって
いう風におっしゃっていただいたんです
けどなんか1日1日をその目的に生きて
いくために何かこう必要なこと大切にした
こと方がいいことこんなことした方がいい
なとかってあったりされれば教えて
くださいうんうんうん
うんまこれやっぱりパターン化するって
すごく大事なんだけど僕はあののケは朝に
あると1年の軽は元旦にありってよく言う
じゃない僕は朝ものすごく大事にしてるの
ねで朝ってね実はね富の厳選と言っても
いいぐらい朝の時間って重要なんですよ朝
自分の人生をしっかりと考えることそして
長期中期短期っていう風にイメージし
ながら今日1日の積み重ねが人生だから
今日という日をいかに納得の行く1日で
するかってことなんね僕は必ず朝自分の
目的目標を確認するそして80対20の
法則というのがあるんだけど2割の優先
事項で8割の成果この2割の核となる仕事
自分の大切な職務をちゃんとあらかじめ
整理しといてそのことを1日の
スケジュールの中でいつやるかを決めるん
ですよそして毎日
必ず終わった時には振り返ることだから1
日のクオリティを高めることなくして人生
のクオリティを高めることはできない僕は
まさに成功とは満足した1日1日の
積み重ねであるとそんな風にも考えてるん
ですね朝起きてしっかりとプランニングし
て悔いのない人生を頑張り
ましょうありがとうございます
[音楽]
はい青木里の人生経営哲学100回聞い
たら豊かになる話それでは青木サのえ人生
系哲学100回聞いたら豊かになる話の第
2回ということで早速第2回目の質問なん
ですけれどもですねやめた方がいいと
分かっているけれどもやめられない悪い
習慣をやめるコツについて是非お聞きし
たいと思いますうん深い
[音楽]
なこれあるよねあのねシンプルにねうん
願望は強い意思は
弱いぶっちゃけね意とが喧嘩すると願望
勝つんですよだから願望と願望ぶつける
しかないんだけどあのま僕はじゃあ具体的
にねどうしたかって言うとやっぱりねあの
自分が今日これを成し遂げたらこれを
食べよう例えば具体的に言うとね
アポイントメントをセールスマン時代ね
いくつ取れたらいくつ以上取れたら夜は
ステーキにしよう
でもねいくつしか取れなかったら夜は
掛けそばだけとかいやこんな風にね
すっごい単純なんだけど人間ってね
やっぱり快感か苦痛かっていうね究極感情
なんですよ人を動かしてるものはだから
そういう風に自分なりにゲームのように
目標を設定して達成したら褒美を与える
自分にこれ人からそういう風に褒でするの
は不快なことなんだけど自分で決めたこと
をやって自分にちゃんと報酬を与えて
あげるそんな風にしていくとま
トレーニングですけどね少しずつできる
ようになると
思うあとはそうだなまもっと言うと
やっぱりこう好きこそ物の上手なれって
言葉があるんだけど裏返すと嫌いは下手の
証拠なんだよねだからその好きになるには
どうしたらいいかって言うとま単純な話が
ね元々好きなことをやるかもう1つはなん
だろう好きになるまでそれをやって達成感
を味わう例えば責任を全頭したとか何かを
成し遂げたっていう時は精神的報酬を自分
がもらえるわけです
よまこれやっぱり納得のこう納得感って
いうかそういうのはすごく大事だなと思う
だ僕はま実は途中で投げ出さないタイプな
んですよあのよく言われるのは青木さんっ
て本当諦めない人ですよねって言われるん
だけど諦めるのが嫌いなん
ですそう
諦めに伴う快感っていうのは実は願望に
あるわけね人はだからそれが癖になると何
でも諦めちゃうんですよでも僕は諦め
なかった時に得られる感動とか快感っって
いうのをま若い時に味わったことがある
から1回やり遂げてみてそこで味わった
ことをもう1回こうなんだ勝利のビシって
言うんだけどねそれがやっぱりまた飲み
たくなる今日決めたことやり遂げたら
美味しいもの食べようまステーキを
食べようこんな風に自分で決めてあの目の
前のことに取りむっていうのが大事じゃ
ないかなと思うま足習慣ってねなかなか
抜けないんですよ昔から飲む使うっていう
じゃないねこれはやっぱりね人間のね本能
から来てるのでどうしてもその快適感情に
流される安きに流されるこれはやっぱり
人間の中にある弱さなんだよねだからま
そういう意味では自分なりに良い仲間
付き合う人を選んだりそれから良い何か
こう習慣うん習い事をするとかなんか
そんな風に置き換えていったらいいかも
しれないね例えばダイエットをしたいのに
ついなんか甘いものを食べちゃうとかそう
早起きをしたいけれどもどうしても2度の
方が幸せなので2度をしてしまうとかって
あると思うんですけどなんかそういう人に
向けて具体的なアドバイスてありますそう
ねダイエットに関してはやっぱり美味しい
ものって当然魅力があるしだから金欲的な
なんかこう我慢辛抱って長続きしないし逆
にリバウンドも来るんですよだからま僕の
ねあの友人であのまある文化人がいるんだ
けど彼女はあの野菜を腹いっぱい食べるだ
からその少量じゃ我慢できないんで野菜を
思いっきり食べるだちょっとドレッシング
は美味しい味付けにするとかそんな風な
工夫をしたりあとは2度2度に関してはね
これはもう即起きた方がいいなもうこれ
しかない特にこれあの寒いとね布団の中
あったかくて気持ちいいもんだから
やっぱり鳴ったら即切るっていうそういう
習慣にした方がいいうん僕はねあの
やっぱりありますよそれ誰でもでもなって
目が覚めたらすぐ起きるすぐ起きるという
のを僕はやっぱりあの習慣化しましたうん
あとはどうしてもそれでも起きれない人は
目覚ましの数を増やすとうんもう本当にね
前にね僕はセールスマネージャーやってる
時に本当に朝起きれない人間のために
目覚まし5個買ってま入り口から順番に
少しずつ置いてけと言ってねまいくらもし
ないのよねその目覚ましをね本当にねあの
プレゼントしてやらせたことありますよそ
も止めてる間にうるさいから止めてくじゃ
ない入り口までそうすると起きちゃうよね
いやだからそれ投資ですまそこまで寝たい
人はねそれぐらい投資をした方がいいよね
うんまあ何でもやっぱ人はねうん願望に
弱いからなそれはやっぱり快適感情に動く
よねでもそこはやっぱりなんとかね自分の
目標やね自分のなりたい姿に対して是非1
つ行為は感情に先行するこの言葉を覚え
といてもらって行為を優先するように
頑張ってほしいと思いますありがとう
ございますちなみに1個聞いてもいいです
か青木社長が断ち切ったなと思える過去足
習慣ってあります
かまいっぱいあるよね僕昔タバコも吸って
たんですよはいタバコも2箱ぐらい吸って
たけどピタっとやめたしそれからどう
だろううんやっぱりお酒も今僕は飲んで
ないよねまあまりねこんなこと言うと金欲
主義者みたいに生まれるんだけどそ
やっぱり癌かけてま今僕の場合は会社の
後継者を指名したらその時はオーパスワ飲
むって決めてるんだけどねそれまで
やっぱり自分に対してま責任を全してたい
うんそう思って自分に癌をかけて我慢し
てるまそんなことがありますよねま
いっぱいそういうことは趣味のように何か
を手に入れるためには何かを大下の先払い
を天は求めてくるだろうなっていうことは
分かってるので必ずそういうことを自分
から進んでやりましたねだからま例えば金
メダリストになろうと思ったら誰にも負け
ない努力も必要だろうし
ま良い高知につくことも必要だろうし原因
と結果の法則があるからその原因を自分で
しっかりと考えて実行していったら必ず
自分が求める人生は手に入ると思いますよ
うんありがとうございます
[音楽]
はい青木サの人生系哲学100回聞いたら
豊かになる話まこのえYouTubeの
テーマがですね人生系哲学100回聞いて
豊かになる話ということなんですけれども
なんかやっぱり続けるってすごくなかなか
難しいことだなと思っていましてその継続
していくポイント3日坊主で終わらない
秘訣ということについて是非教えて
いただきたいと思います
[音楽]
うんこれはね大変難しいテーマですよね
好きこそ物の上手なれとね昔からよく言わ
れるんだけれども
この好きという感情をこう持てるかどうか
好きなことって誰に言われたわけでもなく
て自分からそれをやりたいと自分から
求める心があるというのがやっぱりこう
続けていく1つのポイントなんですよね
ただそのまじゃあ私のま人生振り返った時
にま確かに僕は継続力あると思うんですよ
ねえま僕あの67冊本を書いたんですけど
その中で一生続ける技術っていう本を実は
書いたんですよこれがね実はあまり売れ
ませんでしたでよくよく考えてみたんだ
けどね誰も一生続けたくないんだなという
ことが分かったわけですよでじゃあなぜ僕
はこう続けてるん
だろうま僕は選択理論アチーブメント
テクノロジーというものを日本の筒裏に
広めてえ不満足な人間関係が禁する
あらゆる不幸をこの世からなくしていき
たいまそういう願望があるんですよねだ
から結局私を動かしているのは誰でもない
私なんですよだから何人たりとも人を
変えることはできないし人を動かすことて
いうのは実は本質的にはできてないんです
よねその人自体がしたいかどうかまこれが
ポイントなのでそうすると何のためにこれ
をする必要があるのかというその目的に
対する深い理解とま簡単に言うと本当に
それを心から望んでいるかどうか望んで
ないことを無理やり人にやらせるという
ことは難しいしまたある意味では迷惑な話
なんですよね僕はあのうちの子供たちに
対しても1度も勉強しろと言わずに2人の
子を育てあげましたそれから社員にももう
37年僕は経営してるんですけど1度も
働けと言ったことありませんだから働き
たくなるようにどうしたら仕事を楽しく
できるかとかま勉強の場合は本来はいじめ
とか差別とかそのまそういうもののない
なんて言うのかな内発的に同気づけられる
そういう良い仲間が
いる良い興風がある先生も思いやりがあっ
て真心があって真味になってその生徒に
寄り添ってくれるだから結局その勉強自体
が願望になくても先生のことが願望に入っ
たら好きな先生の授業って力が入るんです
よどういう指導者に巡り合うかっていう
ことも大事なテーマかもしれませんよねま
結局願望って互いに連結しているま
シンプルにに言うと関連してるんですよね
だから勉強はあまり好きじゃないけどこの
先生のことは好きだからこの先生に喜んで
もらいたくて頑張ろうとかま本来なら自分
のために勉強するわけですから勉強その
ものは誰のためでもない自分のものだと
いう理解で迎えればいいんだけれどもま
正直勉強してもお金持ちになれるとか勉強
してもおそれこそ今回のテーマですよね
豊かな人生に入れるとかは子供たちも思え
ないと思うんですよねもう少し突っ込んだ
ところでお聞きしたいんですけれどもでも
実際はそのなんて言うんでしょう嫌なこと
を続けなきゃいけないことの方が多いかな
と思ったりはするんですけれどもなんか
その嫌なことをま好きになるのかあるいは
その嫌なことをなんかこう続けていく方法
と言いますかあればそれ是非ちょっとそこ
を聞きしたいなと思
いやこれはね本当にこのなんだろうな
100回聞いたら豊かに
なるその話のね本質かもしんないんだけど
僕ね実は嫌なことないんだよねいや本当
やらないもんじゃあ会社に勤めてる人で
やらなきゃならないことをやらなきゃなら
ないでもよくよく考えたら
ね
ぶっちゃけ考え方1つだと思うんだよね9
時出社とかいろんなルールがあるじゃん
ルールを守らなければなら
ないそれ嫌なことなんだろうかっていう
ことだよねルールを守ることによって会社
が成り立ってて報酬がちゃんと安定した
ものが得られるんであればみんなでルール
守ろうよってそういう風に深く考えて
ちゃんと理解することが大事なじゃないか
なであとやっぱり覚悟決めるっていうの
かな腹く
るっていうか僕あの毎朝毎晩犬の散歩して
んですよこないだね朝のね3時にねうちの
小次郎君がね泣い
て起こしてくれました僕は起きて行きまし
たうちのかはパパ偉いね私は起きれない
わってかは言ったけど小次郎可愛い
もん可愛いよおしっこ教えてくれたんな
もん感謝だよ検者の中でしない
で外に出てしましたそれは夜僕はちょっと
ね遅く帰ってきたんでかなに夜の散歩は
任してたので何時に夜のおしっこさせた
かって聞いたら6時ぐらいにだってでもう
小次郎君年取ってきたんですよも10歳
11歳になってだ我慢できないだから僕は
小次郎もっと頻繁におしっこさせてやる
からなってごめんなっていう気持ちで散歩
してましただ考え方だと思うんだ俺俺この
考え方がねぶっちゃけね人と違うと思う
もうズバリ言っちゃうと僕はもう本当鉄鉱
上から上がってきた人間なん
で俺頑張ってきたもんもう10代20代
なんて僕本当16時間働てきたからね経営
者ってのはねロキ法関係ないんですよ成果
が出ないと首ですからその首は倒産
ですだうちで学んでる7000人の経営者
の人にも僕は厳しいこと言うんだけど経営
者が長く働いてることによっちゃだめだよ
とそれはある意味で真の能力開発がまだは
できてないからかもしんないよね経営って
人に働いてもらうことなん
で社員が
やっぱり働きもになるような仕組みを考え
なきゃだめそれからね売れなくてねって
言うんだけどそんなもんねいい商品作れて
ねえからだけだろうといいもの仕入れて
こいよともしくは作れよとそれはもう
言い訳抜きですうちの社員でも本当に
頑張ってくれてる人間いっぱいいるんだ
けど本当に感謝してます採用してよかった
なてでもその気持ちを経営者に持たせてる
のは働く人の働き方ですよだどこにも
ユートピアなんかないんだようんだ覚悟
決めてやるってこと以上っって感じかな
ありがとうございますなんか覚悟を決め
るっていうのをなんか具体的に何か行動に
移すとしたらってあります
かどうかな昔さ
ブリタニカで働いてる時のことで忘れられ
ないことがあるんだけどあるそのメンバー
がねあの全体会議みたいなところでその
トップマネージャーが何でも聞いてこいと
あるメンバーが入って手あげてあの
ニューヨークにある1番大きな機関者は
全力で走ってる時は1mのコンクリートの
壁もするパワーがあるけれども動き出す時
にはご寸クがレールの上に乗ってるだけで
前に出れないと記事を読みましたと今私は
そんな状態ですどうしたら一歩踏み出せ
ますかって聞いたのよ彼は赤ちゃんが
生まれたばっかりで血のみがいたフル
コミッションですだコミッションってこと
は集性なんだよ
ね結果が出ないとお金が入らないんですよ
そしたらマネージャーは何て言ったかって
言うとまるまるお前はそこにいろって言っ
たんですよそしたら彼はカチンと来たん
だろうねえどういう意味ですか結果出さ
ないとミルク代も稼げないし具体的に教え
てくださいてそしたらまた言ったの
マネージャーがいいからまるまるお前は
そこにいろってそしたら彼はね開き直った
んだよねそれはないじゃないですかと具体
的にてくれるのが本来じゃないですかてそ
したらマネージャーはね言いました僕あれ
生涯忘れないまるまる君お前なこの全
メンバーの中で1番頑張る理由を持ってる
のがお前だよお前血のみを持ってるお前が
まだお前頑張る理由を外に探してんだろう
だからお前はダメなやつなんだバカて言わ
れたでねここで大事なことな彼がそこで
覚醒して働きもになって稼げるようになり
ましたったら美談じゃんやめたんだよ俺は
分かったのそれで人間とはそんなもんだっ
て農業開発の専門家としてそれが
チャレンジですだから僕は意思は弱いって
ことを分かってんですよ願望です彼に1番
かけていたのは家族に対する愛ですだから
会社でわがまま言うやつは仲間に対する愛
がないんだよねティブthinkキングっ
ていうんですネがってやつですね
ポジティブthinkキングとネガティブ
シンキングがあるんですよ僕はポジティブ
シンキングが洋服着て歩いてる人間
ですだから金持ちにもなったし人待ちにも
なったし本当におかげ様で良い人生を
送れるようになりました僕にはネガがない
んですで1番嫌いなものこの世の中で1番
嫌いなものネが
ですネガティブなものの考え方を選ばない
でネガティブな考え方の人を僕は正直
カウンセラーのようにしてね助けることは
あるサポートもするでも友達にはなりませ
ん残念だけど私はネガティブな考え方は
最悪の趣味だと思ってんですよなぜなら
他石を作るし現状維持になっちゃうし自分
が頑張れない理由をストーリーで描くん
ですよだ事実は1つ解釈は
無数この解釈の中にその人間の限界がある
ん
です私はともかくどんな時でも前に向かっ
て踏み出してきましたうんだからアクセル
とブレーキは思考の中にあるのでま能力
開発の専門家としてあえて言うならば腹
くくって覚悟を決めて1度の人生2度ない
人生
ですもし頑張りたくなければ頑張らなきゃ
いいよさっきの彼みたいにその代わり
赤ちゃんはねお乳飲めないよねミルク代
ないんだ彼はやめて愛な道に入っただから
経者無理ですよねもうねフルコミッション
は無理ですでも私がきた現実は9割以上は
振込みは向いてませんで僕のメッセージを
聞いてくれてる人の中にはうちのお客様も
たくさんいる
でしょう口座の中で私が伝えてること実行
した人で貧しくなった人はいません今回
これYouTubeだから無料ですよでも
私の口座は決して安くないですほも友達の
戸田さんから言われてYouTubeよし
やろうと思ったわけよ俺無償だようんだ
けどただだからと言って軽く聞き流したら
だめです本当に豊かになりたければ今日何
をなすべきか朝早く起きて目的目標を見て
今日1日の行動計画をしっかり立てて8対
20の法則に基づいて2割の優先事項で8
割の成果
それをしっかりと手帳に書い
てもしくはねiPhoneでもいいですよ
しっかり見て自分のともかくこれをする
ことが効果的な成果につがってるのかそれ
をきちっと思考し検証頭の中で考えながら
成果から逆算してやり遂げるそれを毎日
あとはお風呂に入る時には自分の体をこう
してねもマッサージして
ああ今日は本当にベスト尽くしたな
と言いきれる毎日を送ることですよ自分と
未来は変えられる他人と過去は変えられ
ない過去はそれほど重要ではないこれは私
が尊敬する世界的精神科ウィリアム
グラッサーの言葉
です人は誰でも過去の産物ではあるが自ら
が選択しない
決して過去の犠牲者になることは
ない是非皆さんこの続けるということこれ
はですね誰から言われても続けられない
です自分がしたいことを見つけて前向きに
一生懸命取り組んだら良いと思います参考
にしていただければ幸い
[音楽]
です
青木サの人生経営哲学100回聞いたら
豊かになる話それでは青木サトの人生系
哲学100回聞いたら豊かになる話という
ことで他人との比較癖をやめるための方法
はありますかということで是非お答え
いただきたいと思いますうんなるほど
[音楽]
そうねま正直ね僕は人と比較したことない
のねどうなんだろうな私あの芝犬をね2棟
飼ってるんですよね小次郎君とはなちゃ
んっていうこれ2等はね比較してないと
思うんだよね多少サイズの違いはあって
小次郎君は本当は豆柴の予定で買ったんだ
けど大きくなっちゃったのではなちゃんは
やっぱり豆柴なんですよでちっちゃいから
確かに可愛いけど小次郎は小次郎なりの
やっぱ価値があるわけよだから飼主からし
てみたら両方とも価値があるわけだよねで
本人たちというか犬同士も比較はしてない
と思うんですよこんなもんじゃないのだ
から比較するっていうのはね愚かなこと
じゃないかなと思うだってさま僕はあの
父親陽子母親幼女から生まれたんだよねで
3歳で両親別れちゃったわけま義の母に
育てられました本当に感謝してるけど小
学校4回転校してるわけだでまちょっとね
経済的にも非常に苦しい家庭環境だった
からうんま新聞少年ま僕の年代だともう
新聞配達してる人も他にもいっぱいいたん
だけど確かに新聞配達してる子は学校の中
で少数派だよねでも新聞達には新聞配達の
良さがあった僕はその後社会人になってま
営業の世界に入ってトップセルスマになっ
たんだけどあの基礎はねトップセルスに
なったそのメンタルのこう強さとかはどこ
で学んだかって言うと新聞配達だと思っ
てんのよ北海道だから雪が心身降る中軍手
でね系統の手袋なんかできなかったから軍
しながらから一生懸命新聞配達したあれは
トップセールスマン妖精口座新聞配達バー
ジョンってやつなんだよねだから要はさま
人から見たら苦しい状態逆境と言われる
ような状態があるかもしれないけど必ず
その逆境にはそれと同等かいやそれ以上
の成功の種は隠されている
僕はやっぱ考え方だと思ってるんですよ
あげれば気がないほどいっぱいあるわけで
も全て僕はそれを肯定的に解釈して前向き
に生きてきましたうんだからなんかこう
不足感とかうん不平不満の気持ちの強い人
っていっぱい世の中にいるけど俺それが
貧乏の元じゃないかと思ってるぶっちゃけ
俺すっげえ貧乏だった時も心は豊かだった
僕恩師のナ史郎先生に言われた言葉がある
んだよね青木君豊かな人生よりは豊かな
人間になることを求めなさいなぜなら豊か
な人間こそが豊かな人生を遅れるからだ
よっ
てうんその問いだと思う僕は比較すること
なく
ま自分の目の前の課題に真正面から
向き合って一生懸命頑張ってきましたあと
僕あのうちの社員にもねあの言うんだけど
あの自分の給料は誰が決めてるってで実は
一般的には社会では自分の給料は誰が決め
てるって聞かれたらあの普通はね会社が
決めてるとか社長が決めてるとかって
答えるんだよねでもうちの社員は何て
答えるかって言うと自分の働き方が自分の
給料を決めてますって答えるでもそれは僕
がそういう考え方で生きてきたからなんだ
よねだからなんだろう大企業に勤めてる
からいいなとかも全然思わないし大企業に
勤めたら面白くないと思うよ逆に何が
面白いのってだから区役所とかさまこれ
ありがたいよね区役所は大きの仕事でも
役所があるっていうけどさ僕はその安定に
焦点当てるよりも公に尽くしてる仕事に
つけて私は幸せですっていうなら
素晴らしいと思うんだよでも安定があ
るっていうのは安定って自分の働き方が
作るもんだからそんなもん病気したら
終わりじゃんぶっちゃけそうでしょだから
安定なんかどこにもあるわけじゃなくて
自分の生き方とか考え方の中に全てあるん
じゃないかと思うのでまあ僕は人と比較
するっていうのはくだらないと思うま変な
話ね大谷翔平さんって今日本人で最も
おそらく世界で活躍してる人だと思うんだ
けど大谷翔平さんと比較したらどうなる
野球人全ての地球上の野球人が劣等感持つ
じゃんでしまにねそういう人ってどうなる
かって言うとね
わ人形持ってきてね大谷翔平病気になれ
みたいなね横島な頃まで出てくんだよ日と
かやっかみとかなんだろうその足引っ張る
発想絶対ね人と比べない方がいい自分に
与えられた命をまとするもうそれが1番
大事なことです僕はそうやってま少なく
とも生きてきましたそしておかげ様で物面
の豊かな人生を手にすることができたそう
いうことだなでもなんか上を見るとま切り
がなかったり例えば経営者の方であれば
その売上1000億とやっぱりなんかじゃ
50億って比較した時になんか1000億
の方がすごい気がしちゃうとかうん誰が
そう決めてんの誰が言ったの誰が決めた
の1000億ってただ大きいだけじゃん
問題はクオリティです
[音楽]
でお客さんから見たらクオリティしか関心
ないよ自分にとってどんなサービスを提供
してくれるの自分にどんなフォローして
くれるの自分をどんな風に扱ってくれるの
これが1番関心があるわけじゃんそう
でしょだ僕はそこに誠実でありたいと思っ
てるわけだからセールスマンの時も誰より
もお客さんが協力してくれたと思うだから
有力者紹介法っていうねそれを言葉で言う
とそういう手法みたいに言うんだけどうん
いっぱい紹介もらえたのよ俺だからトップ
セールスマになれたわけでマネージャーに
なって僕日本一のマネージャーなったんだ
けどメンバーがめっちゃ働きもんなのよ
うちの僕のメンバーはなんでかってよし
マネージャーを日本一にするぞとかみんな
で最高のチーム作ろうとかそうやって
頑張ってくれたから結果的でま僕が正直ね
やっぱりセルスの時に本気でやったので
技術身につけたよねそれをおしげもなく私
は与えましたよねだからメンバーが優秀に
なっ
てたくさんその人が増えてくから当然
セルスマネージャーで認められるよねまあ
あの私の恩師ナ史郎先生という人に出会っ
て1番大切なものって何だろうとそれは
トロフィーじゃなくて本当に自分が愛を
土台にした納得の行く人生を生きること
だっていうことを学んだわけだよねだから
会社はちっちゃかったけど僕はま黄金率
何事でも人々からしてほしいと望む通りの
ことを他の人々にもそのようにしなさい
これができる仕事だと思って一生懸命働い
たわけそしたら3年で売上7倍になっ
ちゃってでチーフトレーナーになって取締
役になってでその実績で今度32歳で
アチーブメントっていう会社を創業した
わけだよね資本金500万社員5名5年間
苦労があったま苦労じゃないんだけど
トレーニング受けましたまあ最初大変でし
たダイヤモンド社の代理店やったり
ウィクリーていう商品扱わしてもらったり
仕入れはやっぱ信用がないから扱わして
もらえるだけでありがたいんですよ
ダイヤモンド社の商品を扱わしてもらえて
るってこと自体ここポイントなのよ感謝し
ました僕はで前の会社の代理店も引き続き
やってで横綱千代野富士の引退記念の
プログラム作ったら3000セットの大
在庫になっちゃってこれがまた大変だった
だから資金500万から金1000万にし
た時に1億5000万円の在庫だ
もんこれ大変でしたよその時に知恵を絞っ
てよしじゃあこれを50代買ってもらって
代理店になってもらおうとそしてそこに
ちょうど僕はアメリカでタイム
マネジメントを学んでたんでデイタイ
マーっていう英語の手帳をくっつけてそれ
で今のこの口座の原型となる頂点の道で
口座がスタートしたわけでなんとか
乗り切っててもねあの多分ねこの
YouTube見てる人ね誰も知らないと
思うんだけど昔ね巨人の星ってあったわけ
よこれでね知ってる知ってるって人も大体
還暦以上ですね星ヒマって言てさ大2が
妖精ギブスってつけられるわけもう
ギリギリギリとこやって弾投げたりするん
だけどこれ外された時に火の玉みたいな玉
ビーっと投げるわけよ同じなんだよこの
不良在庫3000セットがめちゃ俺を強く
したわけ
でもうちの奥さんにも苦労をかけたんだ
ものすご苦労かけました本当にま社員への
給料の支払いとかね銀行への返済は遅れ
なかったなんとかやりくりしてだけど本当
にま良い訓練を受けましたでもその時僕は
やっぱり家内に対しても恩を忘れてないま
そっからねそれを乗り越えた後会社が
だんだん成長してきてまおかげ様でま
経団連に入れるような会社になり東京商工
会議所の第1号議員にも選ばれたりまそう
いう会社自体は発展したんだけど資本金
500万社員5名の会社が今約社員200
名そして100億円の価値の会社になった
でもこの本質にあるのは真正面から逃げず
に一生懸命努力してきたこれが僕は
元だと思ってるだから比較をし
ない与えられたことに精一杯生きることま
是非お勧めしたいと思います
[音楽]
はい青木サの人生系哲学100回聞いたら
豊かになる話では青木の哲学100回聞い
たら豊かになる話1年間の目標の立て方と
いうことでどうすれば良い目標を立てる
ことができるのか年間目標の立て方につい
てお聞かせいただけます
[音楽]
かそうですねうんまず当然のことだけれど
もその自分はどんな人生を全頭したいのか
という大きな枠組の中から今年1年どう
生きるかっていうことことを考え
るってことですよねま私も常に毎年目標を
達成してきましたけれどもでもそれはうん
目的に対して目標というのはやはり立てる
ものなんですよだから目標の上位概念は
目的なんですよね目的の解概念が目標だ
から目標達成して目的を遂げ
るっていうことなんでじゃあ目的って何
っていう話になるわけだよね人生の目的
ってやっぱり幸せになることなのでじゃ幸
せって何ってことになるわけだけど私が
学んでる選択理論という心理学では5つの
基本的欲求が満たされてる状態だと心身
ともに健康であること愛に満たされた人生
を生きているつまり良好な人間関係それ
から職業で卓越してえたくさんの
ありがとうをもらえる状態それは自分の
価値や
そのま証人力が満たされているっていう
状態それから自由ですよね精神的経済的
自由が得られている強制がない中でしたい
ことができてる状態そして人生を楽しむと
この5つの欲求を出来事の中で満たすって
いうことなんだよねと出来事っっていうの
は何かって言とこれは私はあのまさにもう
40年前になりますよねアメリカで学んだ
タイム
マネジメント当時私が学んだチャールズ
ホブスという博士はあのデイタイマーと
いう世界でも300万人のユーザーを誇る
手帳会社の主席のコンサルタントでまその
タイムマネジメントの分野のエキスパート
だったんですけど時間って何かと時間とは
連続して起こる出来事の出現が時間だと
じゃどうやってタイムマネジメント時間
管理するのかという聞いたら予測理論を使
うって僕はこの言葉で自分の人生が
ものすごく変わったんですつまり出来事は
作れるんだと出来事は起こせるんだと
出来事は選べるんだと未来は選択できるん
だとだ思考の中に未来があるっていう本僕
は書いたんだけど思考によって未来の
出来事を作るだから1年間この5つの領域
の出来事をあらかじめ決める行為これが
プランニングなんですけど何をいつまでに
成し遂げるのかをあらかじめ決めるっって
ことはスケジュールですよね1月から12
月までの間にまず例えば私だった3月19
日は僕の誕生日なんですよと69歳の
誕生日の日ににどんな誕生日会をするかを
今から決めて場所を予約をするとかそれ
から思考デザインするだからこの1年を
どんな風に自分は過ごしたいのかっていう
ことを描きながら5つの
カテゴリー健康面人間関係面職業面蓄材面
趣味教養面この5つの領域でま誕生日や
家族の誕生日や結婚記念日だとかその
イベントの日を全部まず先に確保して子供
さんが小さい場合には運動会とかも全部
確保しちゃうんですよ僕のやり方ってそれ
なんですねだからま去年僕はあのプラハに
家族で旅行したんだけどそれももう1年の
頭の段階で何月にプラハに行くっていう
ことを決めてましたそうするとこの間は
前後で調整をして研修を入れないとかもう
全て色々プランを立ててあとはあらかじめ
ここではこれをすご済ましとかなきゃいけ
ないとかあと例えば社員の給料を払う
手続きをどうするのかとかだから1年間の
出来事イベントそれをあらかじめ頭の中で
考えてスケジュールの中で
この日にこれをしなければならないと決め
たら逆算をして目標達成の手順方法内容を
あらかじめ決めてスケジュールに入れて
いく目標を設定するだけじゃ足りないん
ですよ目標から逆算したプランを立てて
それを1年の経は簡単にありって言うけど
1年のスタートには1年間のプランニング
を持ってるってことですよねそれが大事だ
と思うだから僕は毎年人間ドッグに入る日
だとか10月12日はうちは創立記念日な
んですよまそれももうあらかじめて決めて
そうすとあの紅白まじっていうのを出すの
でそうするといつの時点で紅白まじの発注
しなきゃ全部逆算して全てのイベントを
決める癖があるんですねあの僕はあの車が
趣味なんですねクラシックカーのカラリも
出たり色々するんですけどあと僕今本当に
いろんな会社のおま経営もそうですし役員
もやってるしそしてあの東京商工会所の
議員やったり人事院の委員やったりま
いろんなことやってるんですけどま大学も
3つの一応客員教授やってるんでで僕4月
から事業創造大学に入学するわけですよ
僕が客員教授をやっている大学にMBAを
取るのにもう入学するその年間
スケジュールも全部出してもらいながら
例えばオンラインの単位をどうやって取る
かとかオンライン授業を受ける新潟の学校
なので東京の校舎で授業を受けるリアルで
受けるのはいつなのかとかもう全部逆算し
てでそのプランを実行してを達成するま
来年はねやっぱり本も3冊出すっていう
こと決まってるしあと教育立国推進協議会
に今会長代行やってますから170人の
長頭派の議員と300人の有識者が集まっ
てる会のま会長代行してるのでそれも議員
会館でイベントがあるわけですよね多分
多くの人
は忙しいですねって言うと思うんですよで
も僕全然忙しくないんです実は異人の技術
も使ってるんです私は3人の秘書がいるん
ですけどこれは秘書に任することそれから
直接のラインの営業部門とか管理部門とか
まそれ子会社の場合は出版社だった出版の
社長私は会長職ですからもう全部決めてる
だから未来に起こる出来事を今の時点で
決める行為これまさにタイムマネジメント
だと思うんですよだからゴールセッティン
グっていうのはあの成功のマスター技術
これに変わる技術は他にはないだから未来
に起こる出来事を今決める自由を持って
いるのでうんそこから逆算していき
るっていうことが大事なことだなと思い
[音楽]
ます1年間の目標と1年の計画それは
さっき言った1つのカテゴリーで1度
しっかりと紙に書き出してで具体的に言う
とまずしたいことリストってことをバーっ
と書くんですよで書き出してこれは健康面
これは人間関係面これは職業面これは蓄材
面これは趣味共用面って分けちゃうでそれ
を1回整理してねその中であちょっと健康
面でこれは足りないなとか例えばあのジム
に通うこともそうだろうし重をいつまでに
何キロ落とすとかすっごいリアリティの
ある話ですよねで私は去年からあまりお肉
食べてないんですよまね何回か僕は血液
検査をしたり定期検査をしてるんですけど
ベストコンディションを維持するために魚
を中心にした食生活に変えたりもう全部
コントロールしてるんですねま人生は
セルフ
コントロール目標は自分をコントロール
するツールとして
大事なものだなと思いますけどねあの具体
的な目標設定の仕方に関しては僕の研修に
来てくれるといいと思いますけどねうん
ここで話すとね3日間の研修なので
アチーブメントピラミッドで1番大事にし
なきゃいけないのはやっぱり理念人生理念
自分はどういう人間になりたいかどういう
人生を全頭したいかそれから人生ビジョン
ねどういう自分はやはり人生を送りたい
そこから人生の目標を設定してそれ5つの
カテゴリーですよね健康面人間関係面食用
面蓄材面趣味共用面で具体的なプラン立て
てで日々手帳を使って日々の実践によって
この思いを行動によって成就していくうん
それがま目標達成の技術ということだと
思いますよろしいでしょうかはい
ありがとうござい
ます
[音楽]
青木里の人生経営哲学100回聞いたら
豊かになる話それでは青木サの人生経営
哲学100回聞いたら豊かになる話次の
テーマはお金に困らない人の共通点という
ことで豊かになる人とやっぱりなかなか
豊かにはなれない人っていらっしゃると
思うんですけどお金に困らない人に共通
するポイントどんなもうんか教えいただけ
ますでしょう
[音楽]
かそうねま1つはやっぱり計画的に生き
るってことだよね当たり前なことなんだ
けどその計画っていうのは先に行ってやる
べきことを今の時点で決める行為
とやっぱり頭の中でねやっぱり想像力を
働かせて今あるお金をうんどう管理する
かっていうことですよ
ね入りを即して出ずるを制するとま僕は
若い時から化石に追いつく貧乏なしって
いうタイプでしたうんあんまりねなん
だろうその出をコントロールする意識って
ないんですけど特に僕は人にお金を使う
タイプなんですよ喜ばせることに自分の
願望がそこにあるのであの決してケチでは
ないうんだけどうんなんだろうなその納得
の行くお金を使いたいっていうのあるよね
だからこう納得の行かないお金って嫌なん
ですよどんなことでも納得したいわけで
面白いことになんて言うのかな10万円で
も自分が納得したら全然惜しいと思わない
んだけど1000円でも納得のいかない
ものには惜しいと思うで僕ね笑ってしまう
んだけどねあの川口に僕別荘があるんだ
けど川口湖に行くと必ずね夜ガソリン
スタンドがあるのねそれは今からもう随分
何年も前にそのガソリンスタンドの人が
親切にしてくれてすっごい恩義に思ってて
その後ずっとそこに行くと必ず満タンして
帰ってくるってい修正がある僕はそういう
ことってすごく喜んでももらいたいしお金
を落とすならここでお金を払いたいみたい
ななんかそういうなんかことごとく
こだわりがあるのねでお金ってねやっぱり
投資か消費か浪費なんですよだから投資は
例えば教育なんかは私はうちの子供たちに
対しても青
天井うん青天井ってどういうことかって
言うと上限なしってことですいくら使って
もいいとそして然増よっていう考え方なの
で例えばロシアに行くね以前ねまだ平和な
時代もうどこに行くんでもそれが体験に
つがるものなら
オッケーでもそれをある人はね甘やかすん
じゃないかって言うんだけど違います
ねお金の有効活用なんですよだから僕はね
生き金を使うタイプだと思います死に金は
使わないまま使ってるかな使ってるけど
なんだ完璧完全はないので使ってるかも
しれないけどうんでももしあえて言うなは
それも自己満足というカテゴリーの中で
納得して使って
[音楽]
ますあとはそうね年齢と共にもう60代の
後半になってきてま自分がもう今どう
だろう200歳ぐらいまで生きてもね毎月
200万300万使っても困らないだけの
財は成し遂げてるわけじゃないですかそう
するとお金を残すことを目的に生きる必要
ってないわけでかと言ってそんなには使わ
ないよねお金ってそうすると減らないだよ
もうだからこれ1番何が大事かって言うと
20代30代40代50代60代とこう
いうね年齢的なものがあるとしたら僕の
20代30代は異常に働いてまし
たもうこれははっきり言って胸はって
言えるけど僕以上に働いてる人に会った
ことがないぐらい働いてただその基礎が
あって経験が僕はやっぱり知恵を生んだん
だと思うんだよねだから富の厳選って知恵
なんですようんでも今でも正直あのロス
ある意味では損することもあるそれはうち
の受行生の方々の経営者の会社例えば上場
してるとかね上場しようっていう時には
出資してあげてるわけこれ結構ね株価が
下がってたりもう出端なしで戻ってこな
いってことはあるでもこれも全く僕は悔い
がないなぜなら受行性の支援するのは僕の
喜びだからほらこれ納得ってやつなんです
よ
うんなんだろうなやっぱり納得だよ
ねすごく大事なのは納得っってのはキー
ワードじゃないかな僕の周りで金持ちは
基本的には変なところにケチで変なところ
ていうのはねなんだろうやっぱ無駄が嫌い
みんな生きたお金を使う人が多いと思い
ます
うんあとはね努力って尊いんだけどそれは
若い時だけです経験を積むために必要なん
ですもっと尊いものがあるそれは
チョイス選択の質です努力よりも正しい
選択を優先するってこですね不動産にして
も株にしてもま自分のに対しての投資にし
てもうん僕は今考えてみると選択が良かっ
たなと思う若い時すごい自分づりに投資を
してたから農業開発して
うんまあとどうなんだろうな組織作りに
投資をし
たで1番確かなのは自分の会社を
磨き上げることじゃない毎年リターンが
あるわけだからこれ以上確かなものないよ
ね他人の会社とかアメリカの株のに投資し
たって人がねやってることだから自分の
管理会にはないじゃん1番コントロールが
できないものって賭け事なんですよま私も
ねあのちょっと人とのご縁でお付き合いで
個人馬主にはなってるんだけどでも競馬
ってしないんですよ僕あんまり基本は
なんか16人に1人しか元取れないらしい
よこれあの僕の友達の戸田さんって人から
聞いたんだ
けどそういうことはやめた方がいいねうん
まそんな感じコントロールできることに
投資をするってこですかねはいありがとう
ございますはい